nature the most powerful creative force
on Earth
I'm Chef Melissa King cooking has taken
me to incredible places magical from TV
competitions and celebrity Galas to
countries around the world I'm heading
out to places I've never been before to
seek out new experiences and to create
new dishes inspired by Nature this is
amazing I'm teaming up with some of the
world's greatest explorers to go further
than I've ever gone before this
environment is challenging
to push my craft creativity and my
cooking
this is tasting Wild
Frozen Landscapes fascinate me that's
why I've come to Mount Baker in
Washington's Snoqualmie National Forest
mountains are snow-capped year round
and the land's been carved by glaciers
over millennia
I don't spend a lot of time in cold
climates so I'm excited to be here to
push myself and my craft
leading me on this journey is National
Geographic photographer Keeley yuyen
Keely hey there how's it going I'm so
excited to meet you so great to meet you
so where are we headed we are headed up
the boat
and it's going to be epic all right
let's go all right let's put your stuff
in the car
[Music]
as the National Geographic photographer
it's my job to tell the stories of the
far north and the indigenous peoples who
live in it hopefully my photographs help
to move people to return to connecting
with the land and remembering the
lessons that it has for us and one of
the best parts of being a Nat Geo
Explorer is being asked to impart
knowledge and to inspire people so I
want to immerse Melissa in nature
I've been cooking for 20 plus years and
I'm always discovering something new and
a lot of that has to do with nature not
just relying on your taste buds it's
relying on your sight your smell and
really finding ways to kind of add in
those cues into my food I love that
there's something really ancient about
taste and smell right like you smell
something or you taste something and it
instantly transports you back to that
place where you were when you last had
that
I'm excited to see what's in this River
over here trout and salmon and Great
River fish the Nooksack River which
we're paralleling right now it starts
with the snow up high and then as that
snow melts and becomes a tiny stream it
gets bigger and bigger as it comes down
all that water is the lifeblood of this
ecosystem
yeah we're starting to get into these
places where I feel at home and we
already start to see the snow and that's
definitely what I love
I'm ready for it
[Music]
[Music]
wow
this is pretty much my happy place it's
my new happy place now
this area actually holds the record for
the most snowfall anywhere in the world
in a single year
[Music]
the air is just so crisp and clean here
you could like smell the pine and the
spruce you want to get cured up and head
out yeah let's go
as a chef I'm here to find inspiration
in nature
and apply it to my craft of cooking
there's so much power in this beautiful
glacier
I want to create a dish that represents
everything that we're seeing here
this is very different than California
where I'm from we're used to sunny
beaches
I'm curious what grows here well this
kind of Alpine environment is a lot like
the tundra of the Arctic everything has
to live underneath this layer of snow
for eight months a year will power and
resilience yeah spring comes the snow
melts and they're just like boom here we
go wow and they're reaching for the sky
growing as fast as they can so you can
sort of see all these um little pockets
of life that are just coming out
well here we are you can see where the
snow is all melted away and it's pretty
amazing
this is the Alpine blueberry and those
are the flowers
wow these are so cute they're like cute
little garnishes
let me
I can't resist what does it taste like
it's a little sweetness from the nectar
I love sourcing things locally
and just foraging straight off the trees
and finding ways to really tell a story
through my food because I don't know
it's my love language that's how I think
it's how my brain works I also tell
stories through the building and
crafting of things and one of the things
that I craft and make by hand is
something we're actually going to need
in just a moment so uh yeah why don't we
why don't we head on and check it out
okay I'm curious okay
one of the Striking things about this
place is this is where you can literally
see glacial ice and water carving this
land into the forms at the sea nature is
a master Craftsman that forms the lakes
here
yeah I'm already tired
and here it is
the magic spot
upper Bagley Lake
wow yeah what kind of fish are hanging
out down there well there's brook trout
in some of these Alpine Lakes so
hopefully we'll be able to catch one
I've never caught a fish before
but I'm excited to try yeah right on
yeah so how are we going to get there
well we'll hike around but before we do
first let's grab some kayaks amazing I
am a National Geographic Adventurer but
I'm also a traditional kayak Builder
kayaks are traditional for my nanai
culture so I spent a lot of my teenage
years and early 20s Learning To Build
The Kayaks not only my people but
different communities across the Arctic
which led me on the road to finding
Elders where I was able to learn from
them because I'm holding on to an entire
culture's traditions
[Music]
the kayak smells so good what is it made
of oh yeah so the Eternal frame is
Western red cedar that's what it is
these are all handmade and this is a
millennia old indigenous technology to
this day there are no kayaks as light
and as strong as these these joints
they're actually tied together so that
they have some movement which allows the
joints to flex let's get them in the
water so excited
kayaked a couple times in my life but
never like this
the water is incredibly calm
so still
there really is a peacefulness to this
place
traditional kayaks are special in that
you're not as insulated from the water
itself I hope that Melissa gets the
chance to feel that because the kayaks
Flex she can feel the water and even the
cold through her legs
as a chef we tend to get stuck in
kitchens I love being outdoors I think
that's for me a way that I find
inspiration in a way that I can connect
deeply with what's around me
you're a good teacher teach me how to
make one of these boats building kayaks
is a craft but absolutely what you do is
absolutely craft
it's similar I think I'm sure with you
with but with your boats is it ever
perfect no it's never perfect but I
actually kind of love that too you're
always learning new techniques new ways
to make a dish better or make a boat
better
[Music]
I want to find a way to utilize what's
here in these Lakes to create my dish
but there was brook trout and I'm really
hoping to catch one
did you catch anything
hahaha
the fish aren't really biting
so I'm going to pick up some locally
sourced trout in the morning before we
head out
[Music]
thank you so much for taking me on that
Adventure yesterday it's the coolest
thing I've ever done oh of course it was
super fun for me too I forged for a few
ingredients and I'm really excited to
cook you dinner all right I found a
really cool place up on the top of the
mountain that I'm going to take you to
awesome
[Music]
I hope it works for you now that's
amazing look at that
from here there's the vantage point
where you can see Mount shuksen and
there's ice breaking off the glacier and
tumbling down the mountain
I hope you're hungry
definitely let's set up shop here
right
Keeley why don't you make yourself
comfortable here I'm going to set up the
Prep Station and also start the fire
cool I'm gonna grab my camera actually
[Music]
when I cook I want to transport you to
another place take inspiration from
what's around me and hopefully tell a
story through that dish
all right put me to work yeah you know
we had some Spruce that we foraged I'm
gonna have you chop that up
do you have a knife
sure do
okay you're ready to go
what's the story behind your knife well
this is a traditional life belonging to
one of our neighbory tribes actually and
they're really famous for knife making
yeah it's reindeer antler
what do you use it for I use it mostly
for building kayaks actually but no it's
a great all-purpose hunting knife your
knife and my knife look very different
we have this beautiful trout some Spruce
needles salmon berries these could go
really nicely inside the trout I'm also
gonna throw some lemon slices that is
just beautiful I thought about salt
baking it because to me that represents
the glacier you know all of that snow
that we saw and so here's our mound of
salt
ink whites to bind it all together along
with those different types of pine
needles that we found around the area
the pine salt reminds me of all that
life that was really growing underneath
the snow we're going to bury this trout
right now I know we didn't catch this
fish yesterday but we still are working
with some trout because that's what's in
these Waters I wanted to bring that to
the table well that's why they call it
fishing true
so we're going to hide that trout
beneath the snow cool a little trout
glacier
it's going to be like slow cooking now
when we were up there there was such an
element of time
and everything moving slow and evolving
rather than just grilling the fish I
thought why don't we just slow bake it
when you slow bake a fish with salt
you're really sealing and trapping those
flavors inside
I'm also going to brew us some tea all
right yeah so I'm gonna do some pine tea
with some of those berries that we've
gathered
this trout is going to take a little
while to cook so we have some time to
take in this incredible View
pretty epic to be up here with the
National Geographic photographer hitting
the shutter is like putting the period
at the end of a sentence when you make a
photograph all of the work happens
beforehand and that's just like it is
with you yeah I guess we're cooking the
journey that dish has gone through it
all ends at the moment the person
actually tastes the flavors and the
memories that are attached to it it's
really cool it's kind of amazing how
simile that is very similar all right
let's check out this fish oh cool the
big reveal oh it smells good
yeah
cool that looks awesome
whoa nice just slow cooked right there
it's a big filet for you
oh that's looking perfect
brilliant okay
some others saw severity on there
awesome what a cool pairing
that's yours right there my friend
you're the best thank you all right
should we sit down and eat yeah
such a familiar and lovely smell oh yeah
cheers all right cheers
very good
I'm excited about this
no that's excellent compliments of the
chef well done well done yeah I could
definitely taste the natural Wilderness
it's excellent thank you I've salt baked
many fish in my career but never liked
this and so thank you for just showing
me the outdoors taking me to new places
and helping me find inspiration and ways
that I never thought no thank you really
thank you the only thing that's going to
make this bedroom is if we catch the
fish next time
all right next time singing for trout
you're taking me out okay come babe come
babe
maybe it's the Mountain Air
or the glacial Waters for all of the
life starting to break through the snow
but I'm coming away from Mount Baker so
energized and appreciative
for what Nature has given us here
[Music]